That's just me looking at the
camera, so basically
at the beginning of a competition the camera always comes and
introduces us athletes and then of
course in the best case scenario you laugh, although I
have to say it's really difficult with
no idea the minute before the competition  It's
nice to laugh at the camera again
because you're just like, I'm in such a
beast mode, you could say I'm
so in the in the in the focus, which means I
laugh briefly into the camera and then I'm
right back at it  me and
let this laughter disappear and that's when
I came up with the idea,
I just came up with a sound like that, I ca
n't even describe the sound right now,
um yes, exactly where it
goes from happy to bad and yes that was
n't one  ahnungind 6 second video and it just
went viral, but you can
also predict that a little bit beforehand,
so I can actually
tell you with my content that it will be well
received, that will be very well received, that it
will be mediocre